To understand this a little bit more, let's take a look at a very unique
scenario. Let's say we have a happy, little tank trudging along through a war
zone. The tank randomly fires a bullet into the air, which is actually aimed at
a bunch of little enemy soldiers camping out in the environment. The tank
itself has a small amount of hit points, say three or so. And the mortar in
flight will actually destroy all of these awesome little enemy soldiers up
here. The question for you, then, is this. Which updates first in your update
loop? Let's say, for instance, the infantry update first. Well, this frame, the
infantry, will shoot at the tank and kill the tank, and then the bullet will
update, killing the infantry. This would actually create a level playing field.
An alternative scenario, however, is what if the bullet updates first? The
bullet would actually kill the infantry and they wouldn't have time to update
and kill the tank. In this solution, the tank itself will actually be pretty
happy trudging along through the war zone. Now, there's not really a good
pattern to attack all this. Most networked RTS games actually allow this to
occur quite blindly, and simply ensure that all the clients in the simulation
have the same ordering of entities. This ensures that one client doesn't update
infantry then bullet then tank and the other one do tank then bullet then
infantry. I've also seen some games take a different approach to it, in a
bucketized manner. So, for instance, you may go ahead and bucketize and say
that all of your infantry update first, and then all of your tanks and then all
of your bullets. If you ensure this grouped ordering of entities this allows
you to have the infantry get the upper hand on tanks which gets the upper hand
on those evil, evil bullets. With this layout the infantry would update first,
killing the tank, and then the bullet would update this frame killing the
infantry, leaving a level playing field for next frame.